because the show was not
based on source material and no one knew
who these characters would be and what
to expect from them
the audience went into the first season
with no expectations so
when did you realize how much of a
success the show had become
and that it was connecting with
audiences on a global level
maybe like a couple weeks after it came
out or maybe like a week after it came
out just all of the dms
and um just seeing how many people
walk like watched the first season i
think it was like 50 million
streams something like that and so
yeah it was it was it was nice it was so
amazing to like know that people
actually really really
liked it and they also really connected
with the characters too
megan for you what is it like to join a
show that already has
all of this success is it nerve-racking
to walk onto a set where everyone has
already
spent a season together or is it
exciting knowing that
you're stepping into something with a
fan base and great material
i think it's a little bit of both for
sure um i'm also just sort of
always a ball of of just nerves
so i think that plays into it but also
just the fact that this is a little bit
different in the sense that we were
filming during coven
so we don't really get to have that
personability that you would normally
have on a set
um however it was just really exciting
and and
um they were all so welcoming and really
nice and friendly and that definitely
played a great part into it
there's something for everyone in the
show it's easy to find
something or someone to connect to what
do you guys most
connect to is it something directly
related to your character is it
something related to one of the other
characters
oddly enough i feel like i related a lot
to davey
in season one and just kind of how much
of a mess she was and
a lot of that like second-hand
embarrassment i got from her
um i saw myself in her a lot
um and even season two just the message
when she gets in like picking over like
two people
i feel like i don't know that's a little
bit something maybe i would probably
probably get into maybe a little bit um
she's just a mess and i feel like i
my high school self was definitely
definitely a little similar i wish i
had to pick between two guys i
definitely relate to davey's first
season of not getting
two guys to even like me um
my train i have a no truly um that's
another
conversation um for another day but no
we
my trainee and i we actually have this
this little thing going where we realize
that in real life i'm way more like baby
and she's way more like anissa
um so yeah davey all the way
lee how did the first day of season two
compare to how you felt the first day of
season one did it feel very different to
come back to the show
after having a season of getting to know
this world
and this character yeah i feel like
being on set the first
um scene we shot for season two was
literally the first scene you saw us in
um in season two where we were in the
kitchen
and it was like we were kind of all like
talking about it we're like this is so
weird like we're just
back we're just back here and it kind of
felt like knowing the past a little bit
just
being on set again and so it was pretty
exciting and it was very
comfortable lincoln what did your
first dance set feel like what what was
the first scene that you shot
the first scene that i shot was actually
um
the episode where we're going over to
davey's house for the sleepover and i
got to work my first scene actually took
place with porna and
ranjitha and maitreyi and then i met
ramona shortly after
and we did our scene in the bedroom that
sounds a little weird but you know it's
out of context out of context okay
um yeah and it was porna is hilarious
and she's it was great it was really
exciting but luckily i had laying there
on the side to sort of help me kind of
get into the shoes of anissa and really
establish her um so i think once we
established that and figured out who
anisa was the rest was sort of like okay
i know who she is now
let's play was there a moment that you
felt like you really got into a groove
with anissa you know you jump into the
show you're trying to find
your footing and you're trying to find
your character's footing so did you have
a moment like that
i you know it's funny i don't know if i
had a particular moment that comes
immediately to mind where i was like
okay this this i've got her
because the storyline of anissa the
writers i know that they had an idea of
what her storyline was going to be but
when i auditioned for the role i only
knew
like two scenes of her and it was just
this surface level
you know cool teen that's joining the
school so i kind of
learned about anissa throughout my
journey in these
episodes and i think that kind of helped
just play out organically and i let it
happen the way it was but also
having laying there and and mindy's
feedback really also helped me figure
out who she was and getting
into that for both of your characters
they have
their own romantic journeys this season
lee for you
what did you enjoy about exploring that
dynamic between fabiola and eve and
seeing how much she grew in that
relationship and found her voice
yeah well i mean eve and fabiola are
just very different
in many ways like their interests the
way they dress
um yeah they're just very very different
and so
fabiola's just trying to navigate her
new relationship with eve and trying to
fit in with her friend group and just
you know trying to dress like eve too
becomes an eve clone
and so it's all it's all very um
interesting i feel like for fabiola
because she's just
she's just trying to figure out where
she fits in and she just gets to a point
where it's like
i'm not being you know true who i am and
so
yeah you'll see fabiola struggle a
little bit with like
you know trying to navigate the
relationship but also you know trying to
stay
true to who she is i i love too though
that fabiola
comes full circle by the end of the
season and is able to
only say you know not only do i i love
girls but i love robots this is who i am
and both of those things are a part of
me
yeah how proud of her are you that she
was able to
actually voice that oh my god like when
i saw
um the scene in episode 10 where she
just comes out
and like gears brosnan is like trotting
in front of her
like watching it it felt like such a
special moment that i didn't really take
in while i was doing the scene
and so i feel like i'm very proud of her
i'm so proud of her for like
just figuring out that how she is is
enough and she doesn't have to you know
change how she looks
megan what was it like for you to get to
explore the relationship between anissa
and ben
and seeing what he brought out in her i
mean who's to say
it's ben it can be paxton too
um yeah no
that was really fun also jaren might
just be like the sweetest
man that swapped this planet so that was
really fun
getting to do that with him um but yeah
anissa's a teenager
and she gets crushes really fast
apparently and starts
making out with boys within a week so
shout out to my girl for being free and
loose we also learned that anissa
has had an eating disorder which is
something that a lot of people
suffer with and and suffer within
silence because there's such
stigma to that what was most important
to you as far as
authentically representing that and and
her pain
i i mean that that was what was most
important to me
was being able to make sure that it
authentically represented
people who have struggled or are
struggling with anorexia and making sure
that it's as
sensitive and as you know just i i
wanted to make sure that
i did a lot of research you know
learning about the
the eating disorder itself and how it
affects people but i also wanted to make
sure that i wasn't
playing a prissy teenager this is
something that
deeply affects people and i wanted to
make sure that those moments
seemed very hopefully grounded but also
real
because it is such a real topic in a
very real
um issue uh and i and i hope that anyone
that is struggling there are resources
um at the end of each episode that um
they can you know look into
and um i hope that they can be inspired
to also get help the way that anissa did
the tricky thing to tackle on a comedy
and i think that uh it
definitely did a good job with
portraying you know how it feels to
really have everybody looking at you
about something like that
yeah yeah well thank you thank you i
hope that
other people will think the same
lee what do you hope the representation
of seeing the queen and queen of the
dance
gives to young people who are watching
the show
i mean oh i actually haven't thought
about that but
i hope that that actually becomes more
of a thing where two girls can be queen
and queen where two guys can be king and
king
um and so i hope that actually does that
does inspire something that would
honestly be so awesome
yeah i love how much it's genuinely
embraced i know
well have you guys thought about what
you would like to see
with your characters in season three
about what you know what you would like
to see where you would like to see them
go from here
do you have like a personal wish list of
things you'd like to explore or learn
more about them
i feel defensive about anissa and
honestly i feel like ben did my girl
nissa dirty
how are you going to take me to the
dance and then almost ask davey to dance
with you
that's true nothing but nice um no
so maybe that i need some justice for my
girl anissa
but other than that we're chilling i
would say i want to see fabiola more
comfortable
i want to see more of her relationship
with eve and what it looks like
and kind of how they talk about and like
i feel like i would love to see more of
that and just her being you know
comfortable
and just vibing and a lot more like
friend moments
um yeah
john mcenroe narrates davey's life in
this
if you could have any famous person
narrate your life
who would you want it to be oh my
goodness
i okay i know who but it's not for like
a cool reason it's because i
think i might actually be in love with
him and i just want him to like know
what my face looks like when he's
narrating over me just let i know that
he knows who
i am um pedro pascal
he's also an aries so let's go with that
yeah probably him i just feel like that
would be so fun
and an honor okay and a very good time
i don't know why this person comes mine
but i feel like
actually i feel like this person would
be actually really great to narrate me
royal fabiola
uh queen latifah
yes right yeah it's like the inner
fabiola like just waiting to to claw out
i can see that those are two very good
choices
i i have to say
well in in what way would you say you
are most like
your character how are you most
different from your character and is
there a quality of your character that
you wish that you had
i feel like fabiola how i'm kind of
similar to her is that
she's you know this season she kind of
tried to fit in
and change her clothes and she wasn't
really comfortable with that i feel like
i've had
a moment in my life where i was just you
know trying to do what everybody else
was doing and trying to fit in
it just wasn't working it just wasn't
who i was and
how i felt comfortable and so i feel
like
that i i definitely connected
to that a lot i had to really put in
work for anissa just because i'm
not effortlessly cool i definitely had
lake fisher
cool coaching me on the side sometimes
um
but i what i really loved about our
nissan really kind of took away
is that it's cool to be confident but
you can also be confident and kind like
they kind of go hand in hand it doesn't
have to be one or the other
yeah so that was really cool i think
you're
way cooler than you think you are meg
that's
thanks thanks now i'm starting to sweat
so let's just
not let's not let's not even get into
compliments
well i i think these characters are so
much fun i love
how anissa comes into this as very
unexpected because you don't know what
to make of her and
she just seems really nice and fun and
cool which i really liked
so glad you think that thank you well
thank you guys for talking to me this
show is so fun i loved
getting to see these characters again
and and see new characters in their
world
so i appreciate you talking to me about
it yeah thanks christina